[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
if you'd like to help me produce more
content like this and get early access
to every new video consider becoming a
patron at patreon.com
second thought
now it is up to congress to confront
this egregious assault
on our democracy and after this
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you we're going to walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them because you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show strength and you have to be
strong
we will never give up we will never
concede it doesn't happen
you don't concede when there's depth
[Applause]
[Music]
democrats
[Music]
this is our country
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ufc
on january 6 2021 the world bore witness
to what can only be described as one of
the dumbest days in american history
the hot takes started flying immediately
and the internet was bombarded with
tweets and videos trying to determine
what exactly we were all watching
what do we call it is it a coup a riot
was it planned
who are these people did we know about
it in advance
what do they want i could have deviated
from my normal release schedule to give
my opinions but i decided it would be
more beneficial if i waited a bit
gathered some more information
and provided a more nuanced take on the
event that has so captured our attention
for the past week
this is a huge topic and it involves a
lot of other subtopics
so i'm going to break this video up into
chapters hopefully by the end
you'll have a better picture of what
transpired why it happened and what it
means for the country going forward
before we begin i need to make a few
things clear
first of all the claim that antifa was
secretly behind the riot is not only
wrong
it's incredibly stupid we have mountains
of video evidence of
exactly who was at the capitol including
live streamed vlogs from well-known
far-right figures
conservatives have been calling for
stopping the steel and overthrowing the
government for months
now that an attempt has been made a lot
of those same people
including republican elected officials
are strangely silent
this is what you wanted own it we'll get
into the specifics of who was present at
the event and who was guilty of inciting
it shortly
but i want to make one more thing clear
since donald trump was elected president
pundits journalists and average
americans have taken to using the term
fascism a little too broadly
let me be perfectly explicit here there
were fascist elements within the capital
riot
but you have to use the term correctly
because it is very important
when many people use the term fascist
they're simply describing authoritarian
tendencies
which is where the bizarre conservative
claim of left-wing fascism comes from
i'm making an entire series on the
resurgence of fascism around the world
but to give you a better working
definition in the meantime fascism at
its core
can be defined as paling genetic
ultranationalism paling genetic meaning
a belief in
and desire for the violent rebirth of a
nation to overcome a period of moral
decay
and ultra-nationalism meaning an
overwhelming loyalty to a perverted
vision of one's country
often laced with bigotry and racism be
aware that for the remainder of this
video
if i use the term fascism i mean actual
fascism
not vague authoritarianism with that out
of the way
let's begin with chapter one what
happened
we can take that place
and then do what heads on pike
on january 6 2021 a crowd of thousands
of trump fanatics attended a rally in
washington dc
and after months of unofficial planning
online and further encouragement from
the president
they marched to the capitol with one
goal in mind stop the steal
this slogan came to prominence in the
aftermath of joe biden's electoral
victory
as many die-hard trump supporters
believed the democrats to have stolen
trump's landslide win
this belief has absolutely no basis in
reality
and before you call me a dirty lib
please note that i can't stand joe biden
and i think the democrats are spineless
and ineffective
but you cannot in good faith claim that
donald trump won the election
and yet here were thousands of people
storming the grounds of the capitol
building
erecting crosses and trump flags
breaking windows getting into fights
with capitol police
forcing open doors and finally running
amok in the building
rioters many without a real purpose took
the opportunity to sit in various chairs
collect some souvenirs and take selfies
with suspiciously friendly police
other insurrectionists did have concrete
plans some carrying zip-tie handcuffs in
the hopes of kidnapping members of
congress
or in the case of some of the more
extreme q anon fanatics
executing vice president mike pence for
supposedly betraying the president
for the next several hours the capital
was a scene of jubilation on the part of
the rioters
looking more like an amusement park than
a war zone we saw
all sorts of colorful characters at the
riot from wannabe vikings to special
forces cosplayers to people who still
haven't gotten over the fact that the
confederacy lost their war 150 years ago
seeing confederate flags carried into
the u.s capital as a sign of ultimate
patriotism and loyalty to the nation is
a truly fine example of irony
but the riot wasn't all fun and games
the spectacle claimed five lives
four rioters and one capitol hill police
officer who was knocked unconscious with
a fire extinguisher and then beaten to
death by the patriotic mob
with weapons that included american
flags meanwhile members of congress were
hunkered down in the house chamber with
armed security pointing their guns at
the mob
outside eventually the politicians were
all evacuated without accident
including a number of elected officials
who had helped spread the conspiracy
theory that led to the riot
the rioting continued for some time
trump supporters seeking out mainstream
news reporters and assaulting them and
destroying their camera gear
accosting passers-by and demanding to
know who they voted for
and chanting all sorts of slogans
including hang mike pence
finally hours after the ordeal began the
president released a lukewarm video
asking the rioters to go home
but also calling them very special
people and saying that this is what
happens when elections are stolen from
the rightful victors
capitol police and the national guard
managed to clear out the area later that
night
and the dumbest day in recent memory was
over we'll get to why it was so
ridiculous later on
but next let's move to chapter two who
are these people
as much as conservative figures would
like us to believe that this riot wasn't
a bunch of law-abiding white christian
trump supporters
through the magic of modern technology
we have a very good idea of the types of
people who took part in the insurrection
in no small part thanks to the
participants themselves rioters took
selfies vlogged and bragged about their
activities on all their favorite
platforms giving the rest of the world
a good look at who we're dealing with
now i know i've been snarky up to this
point
but here we really do have to engage
with a claim that deserves a bit of
nuance
many people on the right and even some
other sources have made illusions or
outright asserted that the capital riot
was the result of working-class
americans being pushed too far
on the surface this seems reasonable
most americans can agree that things
haven't exactly been going well for the
working class regardless of your
politics
over the course of the pandemic
billionaires have become vastly more
wealthy while tens of millions of
americans have lost their jobs
their health insurance and their homes
the system favors the rich in this
country
but to paint the capital crowd as honest
hard-working folks is less than accurate
for years the media has loved to engage
in rural diner fetishization
where they find a poor trump supporter
and condescendingly try to understand
them
these people do exist and it's a shame
that they've been so lied to by the
republican party
but from what we've seen from social
media and coverage of the riot
a large percentage of the crowd was not
working class at all
but rather wealthy conservatives who
just wanted to be part of the excitement
take these guys for example yelling at a
handful of dc police
[Music]
these are the people that republican
policies benefit not the workers these
business owners employ
in the aftermath of the riot the fbi was
quick to put out a request to identify
anyone at the event
the anti-trump crowd was only too eager
to oblige which is a problem we'll
discuss later
but regardless what we've learned about
the crowd so far should not be
surprising
among the attendees were the ceo of a
tech company lawyers high profile
attorneys
republican elected officials both
current and retired the son of a
brooklyn supreme court judge
and this woman a real estate broker from
frisco texas who flew on her private jet
with her wealthy friends to have some
fun breaking windows
as is typical in america the wealthy can
brazenly commit crimes
brag about it and face no consequences
this woman described the riot as
one of the best days of my life she went
on to say this is a prelude to war
and if we know anything about war it's
that she will be far away watching all
the commoners die while she and her rich
friends continue to live lives of luxury
i won't disclose the names of any of the
people i discuss in this section
unless they're already well-known or
public figures you can find them easily
enough online if you're interested
the owner class was not the only group
of people at the riot
there were also off-duty police and
military personnel who
according to official statements flashed
their badges and were simply let into
the capital to wreak havoc
seattle pd released a statement that at
least two of their officers had attended
the riot
and off-duty cops from all over the
country flew in for the event
as we learned over the summer where
there are cops there are white
supremacists
and the capitol hill riot was full of
them both the really obvious kind
and the kind that looks a bit more like
your parents or your crazy uncle
the kind that don't see themselves as
racist as reported in the nation
one woman said this is not america
they're shooting at us
they're supposed to shoot at blm but
they're shooting the patriots
after months of trying to explain to
people that the average white
supremacist genuinely believes black
lives matter supporters are terrorists
hears a woman saying it out loud
saying that america is supposed to shoot
the people protesting police violence
not the people trying to overthrow the
government for a loser president
as despicable and deeply absurd as that
statement was
this woman represents the mildest form
of white supremacist present at the
rally
we also saw literal nazis this is where
a lot of conservatives shake their heads
and say you can't call everyone you
disagree with the nazi
i'm not i'm calling nazis nazis this guy
is wearing a camp auschwitz shirt
bearing the words work brings freedom
this one is wearing a shirt that means
six million wasn't enough
referring to the number of jews murdered
during the holocaust
neo-nazi's social media personality
baked alaska live streamed from inside
the capital
that viking guy from all the pictures
that's jake anjali
known by many as the kuanan shaman that
symbol he's got tattooed on his chest is
widely used in nazi and white
supremacist groups under the guise of
appreciating european heritage
we saw people flying the keck flag a
symbol birthed in the bowels of 4chan
modeled after the swastika
and like so many other internet symbols
easily dismissed as
just a meme nsc 131 was there they're a
neo-nazi group based in new england and
very active on telegram
they said they would show up and they
did proud boys founder and author of
10 things i hate about jews gavin
mcinnes was spotted at the riot 2.
so the next time someone claims the
trump cult is not totally infested with
all manner of white supremacists
send them this video we have
photographic and video evidence
these people were all over the capital
and after the event
they were all over the internet trying
to convert the run-of-the-mill ignorant
trump supporters
ironically even having to explain to the
less extreme conservatives that no
antifa are not the real fascists we the
nazis are the real fascist and you
should join us
it's the type of thing that normal
americans would never expect to be going
on in the political undercurrents of the
internet
but here we are so we've seen business
owners millionaires q and on cultists
white supremacists
and literal nazis in the crowd at the
capitol who else would you expect to see
there
if you said republican elected officials
congratulations you're right
to anyone paying attention it shouldn't
come as a surprise that some of our
fearless leaders took part in the
insurrection many republicans have been
helping to spread the lie that trump
actually won the election
west virginia state lawmaker derek evans
was there as were former pennsylvania
state representative rick saccone
virginia state senator amanda chase
incoming co-chair of the michigan
republican party michonne maddock
missouri state rep justin hill tennessee
state rep terry lynn weaver
nevada state assembly member annie black
and likely others who were smart enough
not to show their faces on camera
other republicans chose not to attend
and instead tweet their support or pull
the strings behind the scenes
colorado congresswoman lauren bobert
tweeted out today is 1776
and america is depending on all of us
today this is something i don't take
lightly
i will fight with everything i have to
ensure the fairness of the election
you know like overthrowing the
government and tossing out the
legitimate results to reinstate the
loser
senator josh hawley offered a fist
raised in support of the rioters as he
entered the capital to vote on scrapping
the electoral college results
this vote was interrupted when his
buddies started smashing up the place
but when congress reconvened later that
night to finish voting
eight senators and 139 house
representatives still cast their lot
with trump and his absurd lies
to no one's surprise all republicans so
to sum up the crowd at the capitol hill
riot it's an accurate depiction of what
the republican base has become
misguided workers swindled by a cult of
personality wealthy business owners
q anon cultists white supremacists and
elected officials who would gladly fall
on their sword to please donald trump
let's move on to chapter three
okay so we know what happened and we
know who's responsible
but why did they do it what was the
reasoning behind the riot
just like there was no one single type
of trump supporter in the crowd
there were many distinct goals among the
rioters for many
simply getting into the capitol building
was a victory it didn't accomplish
anything but it made them feel good
for others there was a much more
sinister goal in mind remember the
picture of the guy with the flex cuffs
at least some of the insurrectionists
were hoping to take hostages
what they intended to do with them is
anyone's guess but judging by the fact
that they were chanting
hang mike pence the republican vice
president it doesn't take much
imagination to assume that they were
perfectly willing and probably eager to
harm any democrats they could get their
hands on
but there was one overarching goal that
united the mob
stop the steal simple slogans like stop
the steel
are incredibly effective they provide a
rallying cry and a reminder of what they
hope to achieve
in this case the end goal was
overturning the results of the election
and installing donald trump as president
instead of joe biden
donald trump a man who gave these people
next to nothing
only cares about himself and his rich
buddies and who lost the electoral vote
and the popular vote by 7 million votes
the word coup has been used a lot in the
last week in some regards it's
appropriate
there was a group of people who tried to
violently change the result of an
election
but on the other hand look at what
happened once they breached the capital
most of the crowd just started messing
around they sat in some chairs
stole the speaker's lectern took some
selfies chanted some slogans
but that was it they didn't go to any
other government buildings
they didn't pursue evacuating
politicians as far as we can tell
they didn't really have any concrete
plans at all not to step on any
patriotic toes
but it doesn't really count as a
revolution if you're trying to keep a
president in power
when other countries riot and storm
their seats of government it's usually
to demand changes that will materially
improve their lives
what will keeping trump in power
accomplish he doesn't care about the
working class who actually need material
help
and the millionaires won't suffer under
a biden presidency
biden is a corporate centrist dedicated
to maintaining the status quo
and that means continued pandering to
massive corporations and crippling
austerity for the rest of us
but at the end of the day donald trump
disowned the crowd
conservatives he threw you under the bus
when the riot became inconvenient to him
this is something that many on the right
are beginning to come to grips with
this whole time trump wasn't a
mastermind he wasn't playing 4d chess he
was just a bigoted old man who knew how
to push the buttons of his followers
he's a showman
he played his followers encouraged them
to fight for him and then cast them
aside when they risked their lives to
deliver him the presidency
so no this wasn't a coup i suppose you
could make the argument that if somehow
they had actually captured the entire
government it would have been an actual
coup because then they could have made
real demands
but they didn't and there's no
indication that it was organized enough
to do so
nor were there any specific demands
behind the slogan stop the steel
the crowd may not have had any real
chance of success but regardless of
their effectiveness there will be very
real consequences for the people of the
united states
in the aftermath of the capital riot
we've begun to see a social media
crackdown
and the expansion of the surveillance
state the president was suspended from
twitter
along with over a hundred fifty thousand
other accounts including over seven
thousand related to cuanon
parlor the most well-known hive of white
supremacists and q anon followers was
threatened
and then suspended for refusing to
moderate hate speech and content
inciting violence
at which point a reported 600 thousand
new users flocked to gab
another site willing to host their
hateful ideology the discussion around
social media censorship is fraught with
some asserting that banning vile
accounts is a good thing
while others claim it's a slippery slope
and will be used against any number of
other groups
if you want my two cents here goes you
can be glad to see
fascism dealt a body blow and also
concerned about the precedent this sets
at the same
time fascism white supremacy nazism
cults completely detached from reality
these are all objectively bad
limiting their recruiting power is a net
good do tech companies have too much
power in curating the online
conversation
absolutely but i won't cry over the loss
of literal nazis
for those who say this will be used to
justify banning left-wing accounts
trust me i know censorship and bans have
been leveled at the left for years
it's not like suddenly we'll face a new
threat this already happens all the time
tech censorship affected the left far
more than the right up until the capital
hill riot
because the u.s is vastly more afraid of
communism than it is of fascism
all that aside now that the right is
getting a taste of the free market
deciding not to put up with their
nonsense
maybe we'll actually see a growing
consensus that corporations have too
much power
perhaps more concerning than the social
media crackdown is the new justification
for state surveillance
the fbi are suddenly the good guys for
trying to identify right wing agitators
many on the left are gleefully turning
in co-workers to the feds
and this is exactly what the powers that
be want
this whole debacle is an incredibly
convenient way for our leaders to
normalize asking us to turn in our
neighbors for perceived crimes against
the state
today that crime is breaking windows at
the capitol but what will it be tomorrow
i got a visit from dhs for supposed
anti-american sentiment in my videos
how long will it be until making youtube
videos saying we should improve society
is a crime against the state
to emphasize my point and to quote the
wall street journal
mr biden has said he plans to make a
priority of passing a law against
domestic terrorism and he has been urged
to create a white house post overseeing
the fight against ideologically inspired
violent extremists and increasing
funding to combat them
well that's delightfully vague isn't it
even if biden were to define terrorism
as something most people agree upon
there's nothing stopping the next
president from criminalizing something
entirely different
this legislation will 100 be used more
viciously against the left than the
right
look how the black lives matter
protesters were treated it was a
bloodbath and they were far more
peaceful than the capitol hill goons
i guarantee you that black lives matter
will be classified as ideologically
inspired violent extremism
laws that are left intentionally vague
like this give the state a blank check
to commit acts of horrible violence
against their citizens
there is a precedent for this at the
height of the red scare
there was a group known as the house
unamerican activities committee
its prime function was to conduct
investigations or more accurately
baseless witch hunts under the direction
of joseph mccarthy
from whom we get the term mccarthyism
the accusation completely without
evidence that a u.s citizen is guilty of
treason for being a suspected communist
i don't think you have any conception of
the
danger of the communist party i want to
make it clear
that the united states army does not
cuddle communists
unsurprisingly we see a lot of this
behavior even today
many of the rioters were certain they
were the only thing standing between the
united states and communism
and news networks routinely equate
communism with fascism
completely ignoring the fact that the
u.s allied with the communists to defeat
the fascist in world war
ii which would indicate that one is
indeed worse than the other
but regardless of how you feel about
your friendly neighborhood communists
biden's new anti-terror legislation will
result in the baseless arrest of
innocent americans
another consequence of the cue data or
beer gut push if you prefer
is the enacting of a new batch of no-fly
orders here's some footage of a rioter
who's just been informed he can't get on
his flight because he was identified as
being present at the capitol love every
single one of you
as much as watching mildly inconvenience
trump supporters may delight some people
we need to again think about this in
terms of state abuse of power
pair this no-fly rule with biden's
proposed anti-extremism legislation
are climate activist extremists black
lives matter protesters
am i an extremist since i've been
visited by the dhs if i were to
participate in a march for medicare for
all in dc
then i tried to get on a flight back
home would that trigger an arrest
anti-terrorism laws always always always
have disproportionately negative effect
on the population they're supposed to
protect
this time will be no different one final
consequence of the riot is the proposed
impeachment of donald trump less than
two weeks before the end of his term
i get it he played a role in inciting
his supporters to do violence
but casting trump as the source of all
america's problems is foolish
if we allow him to become this
sacrificial goat all the sins of the
modern gop projected onto the supposed
anomaly that is trump
we're letting republicans off the hook
for what has become mainstream
conservative thought
trump is not an anomaly he is the
embodiment of american conservative
ideology
fully 45 of republicans support the
assault on the capital
and that's just those who will admit it
will removing trump from office send a
symbolic message that even a president
can't get away with everything
sure in theory but i just don't see it
happening in order to maintain the
national myth of moral superiority the
president must be above the law
the president's job is to do horrible
things order assassinations around the
world
bomb schools and hospitals overthrow
governments and install puppet regimes
enact crippling sanctions to starve
entire countries the only difference is
that trump incited a bit of violence at
home
the question is will kicking him out or
keeping him in
better maintain the facade of moral
superiority that will determine the
result of any impeachment hearings
which will probably already have
occurred by the time this video goes
live
okay this episode has gone on long
enough let's move on to the final
chapter
what does all this mean for american
politics and the future of the country
they're going to have to we need a
republican party we need an opposition
that's principled and strong
i think you're going to see them going
through this idea of
what constitutes the republican party
let's start with this ridiculous
statement
we do not need a strong republican party
a strong republican party just tried to
overturn the results of the election
we need to be honest here the republican
party has gone completely off the rails
they have open contempt for 99 of
americans
they think their voters are morons many
of them are white supremacists and have
zero regard for actual democracy
but more than that a strong republican
party is what has allowed democrats to
get away with doing nothing for years
universal health care wish we could but
those darn republicans are making it too
difficult
investment in green energy geez sorry
the republicans need that money for the
military
police reform well we would but the
republicans are stonewalling
the only reason the democrats want a
strong republican party is because the
two parties rely on each other to
maintain the status quo
they are both right-wing corporate
parties behold into massive corporations
and billionaire donors
they play the identity politics game
casting each other as the greatest evil
and a threat to the american way of life
leadership changes hands every few years
and nothing ever changes
if biden actually wanted to make real
positive
lasting changes he would be taking
advantage of the capital riot and
blasting the republicans 24 7.
not asking people to be nice and unify
with them from people besides the
political establishment i understand the
calls for unity
i really do it would be much nicer if
everyone could just get along
but that is nowhere close to the reality
of modern america
we are more divided than ever and in
ways that are fundamental and impossible
to compromise on
the people who stormed the capital think
jews black people
gay people and countless other groups
are subhuman and deserve to be
exterminated
i will not concede one inch of
ideological ground to these people
i will be understanding of working class
trump voters who have real economic
concerns
millions of americans share those
concerns but we cannot stoop to
barbarism and defend heinous ideas with
the shield of economic anxiety
the capital riot has made many things
clear one of them is that the blue lives
matter movement was never about
respecting police
it was about supporting cops brutalizing
black people it was a deeply reactionary
ideology like the rest of american
conservatism
any economic progress must come without
the baggage of white nationalism
fascism or any kind of bigotry espoused
by trump's most vocal supporters
the late michael brooks always said be
kind to people be ruthless with
institutions
trump voters are our fellow human beings
we have to do what we can to help them
shed their bad ideas without labeling
them all a lost cause
the republican party on the other hand
is a lost cause
it has shifted so far to the right that
it's flirting with ideas that should
alarm every american
not just the left we have republican
elected officials suggesting that
democracy is mob rule
and that it's a bad way to organize a
nation the modern democratic party is as
far to the right as we should entertain
the republicans have dragged the
democrats to where the republican party
was three or four decades ago
we do not need two right-wing parties in
america
we need to relegate the republican party
to the trash heap and build an
actual left party to balance out the
corporate democrats it's also been made
clear that the democrats are just as
willing as the republicans to use
authoritarian tactics
in the wake of the george floyd protests
biden has said that he wants to increase
police funding
in the aftermath of the capitol hill
riot he's said he wants to expand the
surveillance state
the grip of the state tightens with each
new administration republican or
democrat
that being said the democrats have not
yet instigated mobs to try to change the
outcome of an election
the republicans have done it twice in
the last two decades and they got their
desired outcome in 2000.
the last thing we need to consider is
that there has to be nuance when
discussing uprisings like this one
people will always try to judge things
by a universal metric
saying things like it is always bad to
use direct action against the government
resisting the government is not itself
inherently wrong
it's what built this country the reason
the capital insurrection was bad was not
because of the nature of uprisings but
because its reasons were pointless and
terrible
what would overturning the election
results accomplish giving the loser of
the election power and that's it
donald trump has been an incompetent
president he's weakened our alliances
with friendly nations
made new enemies refused to make common
sense reforms or pursue climate goals
disarmament or any humanitarian projects
and has not materially improved the
lives of average americans in any way
keeping trump in power is a bad reason
to storm the capital consider why
other nations rise against their leaders
to oppose crippling austerity
to demand better healthcare or necessary
reforms always things that materially
improve the lives of the vast majority
of citizens
it would be foolish to look at the trump
riot and a hypothetical uprising over
healthcare and say
these two things are the same we in
america have completely lost our
understanding of class struggle
i can't imagine a more counterproductive
effort than trying to overthrow the
government to keep the rich guy who did
nothing for you in power
as a result we've got increased police
budgets increased surveillance a social
media crackdown and sweeping new vague
anti-terror legislation
if you're going to make a fuss at least
have concrete demands and make sure it's
for a good reason
healthcare is the obvious example that
comes to mind in america because our
healthcare system is the most expensive
in the developed world
routinely bankrupts people has the worst
outcomes of any developed nation
and goes away completely when we lose
our jobs which we found out is pretty
devastating in the middle of a pandemic
so to sum up a very long and frustrating
topic the capital riot was a foolish
display of the worst tendencies of
american politics
it exposed the ugly underbelly of modern
conservatism
and the government response to it is
also incredibly alarming
we are living in what's becoming more
and more of a police state with a
petulant loser in charge of the nuclear
arsenal
where half of americans choose to cast
their lot with bigots racist
exploitative billionaires and literal
nazis we have no concept of what actual
progress would look like
and the incoming administration is
addicted to failure and terrified of
actually having the power to govern
we're in a tough spot and if the last
week has proven anything
it's that the rest of the world is
watching closely
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is
supported by my patrons on patreon
this kind of video while very important
is something that sponsors won't touch
to keep my channel running i rely on
sponsors adsense revenue
and donations from generous viewers by
producing content like this i lose out
on both sponsors and adsense
if you enjoy the kind of videos i'm
producing and you're able to chip in
even a dollar a month i would greatly
appreciate the support
you can find my patreon page join our
discord server and get early access to
every video at patreon.com
second thought if you enjoyed this video
consider dropping a like
if you hated it a thumbs down you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
[Music]